and I remember when they were taking
this I was like oh geez it's archivable
history now I'm here today to go back to
this which is gonna be scary
my name is Dean Briana wits I'm known as
the Hollywood hair guy my name is Jarrod
I have my hair restoration about six
years ago growing up it was I always had
really thick hair it was nice full head
of hair anyway I wanted to cut it bleach
it diet and I remember going into the
army that's when I started to notice the
thinning right around 2022 and it really
made me research on where I wanted to go
to keep it because I like hair men are
just as needy about their hair and the
thing is is it just starts to really
chip away at your confidence when I
initially found out that Bosley offers a
free consultation I went ahead and set
up an appointment and I went through the
process and the counselor and the doctor
and everybody at Bosley were really
amazing and they explained it explicitly
to me like every single thing that's
gonna happen the best part is no one
even knew I had it done because you
couldn't even tell like now I see the
difference and it's something that like
I can run my hands through who's gonna
run their hands do that work it out
[Music]
listen there are so many beautiful bald
men cuz if you've got a great shaved
head be bald if you want to be bald I
would never get a date Wow
cuz I look like my brother Steve and my
brother Alan I mean I love them seeing
myself now my hair would definitely be
like this and plus I'm a Leo it's all
about the hair the lion now I'm kind of
a cub the world's not ready for this
Jerry okay so here I am I'm about to go
into the grocery store I'm a little
nervous you never realize how many
reflective surfaces are in a grocery
store I just got home let's see what
they say just got home
my assistant hasn't seen it he's coming
out of the office
right how do you feel about that how do
you think I feel I would be single
forever I'm ready for my hair back
[Music]
glad that's done I have to say thank you
to Bosley because I've definitely made
me look in a positive direction and not
just wondering what had I'm gonna wear
each day
[Music]